R is the leading programming language for statistics and data analysis.
One of the main advantages of using R is that we
can build up an analysis line by line in code. We
can save all of our work in a file and go
back to see what we investigated at a later date. Having
R scripts allows you to easily share your work with others.
And you can see what others are doing with data. R
also has over 2,000 user contributed packages that increase its functionality.
One example of this is the text analysis package, TextCat, that
you just saw. Now, one of the main packages we'll use
throughout this course is ggplot2. Ggplot2 is a graphics package that
let's us create plots And graphs with just a few commands.
We'll learn more about ggplot in the next lesson but just
to give you a taste of it, here's an example of
a plot you can create. Now, don't worry about memorizing or
understanding all of this code. You'll have plenty of practice with
this later in the course. I just want to show you
how a few lines of code, can create amazing graphics.
I'm going to load up the ggplot library and a color
library. Then I'm going to load the diamonds data set, and with
this function I'll create a scatter plot. Let's check out
this plot in detail. This part shows the relationship between price
and carat of almost 54,000 round cut diamonds. I'd say
R is doing very well for such few lines of code.
The last thing I want to mention is that you
can use R anywhere. It's free open source software that
works on any operating system. And as a result of
this, R has a large active and growing community of users.